How did I go about volunteering internationally?
All paid?
This is me,
I went to Lima in September for three weeks with the Pacific Alliance program.
It was an experience that undoubtedly marked my life and it was
all thanks to the Pacific Alliance.
The Pacific alliance,
for those who do not know,
is a regional integration program between Mexico,
Chile,
Colombia and Peru.
More than a free trade agreement,
it focuses a lot on this issue of integration and that is why it also
offers scholarships and volunteers,
as is the case of youth volunteering.
Every year the call comes out approximately in May,
in which you can apply to participate in programs for Mexico,
Chile,
Colombia or Peru.
There are 4 brochures in which you can apply and
each country has a different theme.
There are topics such as mental health,
feminism,
agroecology,
agriculture,
etc.
The point is for you to go to the Pacific Alliance page or their Facebook page,
turn on notifications and when the call comes
up you will read all the requirements.
In my case I applied to Peru that the topic was mental health
in adolescents and their community,
therefore we offered interactive workshops in which we talked about
very important issues such as resilience,
self-love,
generating support networks,
etc.
People from Colombia,
Chile,
Peru and Mexico are also participating in this project,
so it is a multicultural experience and it is also a super enriching
experience because you learn more about other cultures,
learn more about experiences in important issues such as mental health
and these people eventually become your soulmates.
Part I had the opportunity to travel to another country,
here I am in Lima and eh,
because it included the plane tickets,
the lodging,
the meals,
clear,
the transportation Clearly did not include the trips,
but eh I had two days off,
so I had time to get to know different parts
of Peru In addition to volunteering,
I got to know Lima,
I got to know the crossbow islands,
I got to know the Ica Strait,
different things.
So here's your chance to apply to the Pacific Alliance volunteer
program and if you have any other questions you can post
me in the comments or send me a message.